we have been on the sets of these epic
films from the very beginning and the
thing that we have noticed is that the
women of Marvel do a great job of
holding their own against the man
oh I kick some hands yes I was an
introvert with asthma before this movies
got coming with an army who look just
like me it's kind of an injection of the
different the women of Marvel have up
their superhero game starting with the
first time we met Scarlett Johansson as
Black Widow in 2010 iron man 2 it's
something I don't like comic books but
I've never really I've never been a huge
fan of comic books nor thinking about
Dubois
Scarlett was pregnant and still doing
some of her own stunts while shooting
2015 age of Ultron with 8 Marvel movies
to her name she's now in pre-production
on her own Black Widow feature - 4 year
old daughter Rose ScarJo is the coolest
mom ever what's really exciting is being
able to have her just see that she does
[Music]
it's too great opportunity to deny
Guerrero and Lupita Nyong'o first
brought their fierce brand of female to
Wakanda in black panther but it wasn't
easy
it was quite child it was not easy it
was
dedication you know we least we had a
boot camp for like six weeks before the
filming started you know how two
brothers play yes
I've had a lot of long plane flights in
my little pod by myself to just reflect
on my life and go like how did I get
here what is happening to me but taking
them all higher further faster brie
Larson the first woman ever to helm her
own Marvel movie I'm not gonna fight
your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it and although Captain
Marvel brought in over a billion dollars
at the box office we did not dare snag a
set souvenir are you Jeannie it was like
my first day at school
like I was gonna mess it up I'm just
trying to like be polite and figure my
stuff out and like not have a new store
like attached oh I'm still stronger than
you though mmm
[Music]